rodgeur rodgeur on a un problème rodgeur
rodgeur on a un problème
[Musique]
ceci est un téléphone
et ceci n'est pas un téléphone ceci est
bien plus qu'un téléphone
ceci est très gros ceci est un téléphone
qui peut aller de moins 30 à plus 60
degrés ceci est le nouveau téléphone
haut de gamme de la marque dodge y
marque chinoise qui vous promet un
smartphone résistant pour l'extérieur un
smartphone qui est destiné à tous les
amoureux des aventures extérieures parce
qu'il craint pas du tout il a plein de
certification je vous détailler dans
quelques instants
et il est aussi destiné à toutes les
personnes qui vont travailler à
l'extérieur le btp parce qu'il ya plein
d'outils pour mesurer plein de trucs
hyper cool vous avez une antenne qui est
complètement démontable enfin un truc
complètement fou dans la boîte
il ya plein de trucs qui sont très
pratiques je vous le montre voici le s80
de dodge il est franchement et l'arrière
plutôt cool d'autres js 80 bornes francs
extreme c'est un smartphone qui est
vraiment fait pour l'extérieur pour
l'outdoor bon boîte qui cassent pas
quatre pattes à un canard qui a un côté
un petit peu green un peu écolo qui fait
un peu papier recyclé mais bon plutôt
sympa robuste pour la voix il est énorme
la boîte parce que le smartphone est
tout autant énorme alors normalement le
smartphone je vous enlève l'antenne
il est situé comme ça à l'intérieur il
est juste costaud énorme mouse c'est
vraiment très très très grosse bête vous
enlevez tout ça à l'intérieur vous avez
quelques infos pour votre smartphone
vous expliquer comment il marche vous
retrouver ici
la partie centrale pour le côté talkie
walkie vous avez bien évidemment une
antenne vous avez un blog de charge
rapide 24 watts
je vous expliquer pourquoi on a vraiment
besoin de recharge rapide la tumeur très
important et on va retrouver ensuite
quelques petits accessoires vous avez
ici un port usb type sévère prise jack
parce qu'il n'y a absolument pas de
prise jack sur le smartphone vous avez
ici une prise usb vers usb type c est
vous avez ici une prise se mêlent usb
vers usb type c'est ce qui permettra de
brancher des accessoires des trucs enfin
toc est vraiment bien fait vous pouvez
l'utiliser soit en smartphones comme ça
il est franchement très très gros il
fait quasiment 400 grammes il fait pour
être précis 398 g surtout depuis que les
différentes confie donc leur téléphone
et on cite l'utilisent en talkie walkie
on vous ouvrez ici vous venez vie c'est
l'antenne vous installer ça voilà vous
le mettez dans sa boîte et là vous
pouvez venir l'attacher à votre ceinture
vous le régler comme vous voulez
franchement c'est plutôt cool et c'est
très pratique vous avez ici son côté
bouton de volume bouton pour l'allumer
pour l'éteindre en dessous vous avez ici
votre zone où vous allez pouvoir
brancher votre usb type c qui est
positionné juste là là ici en dessous
ensuite sur le côté vous retrouvé vos
boutons ici pour utiliser sur la
fonction talkie walkie
ici la petite partie pour venir insérez
votre carte si vous avez 6 2 cartes
nanosims si vous souhaitez le faire à
l'arrière vous avez un double module
photo 12 + 5 mégapixels avec l'ouverture
de fo point 8-7 une caméra sony mx360 3
vous avez ici à l'avant une caméra
samsun de 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.0 et un grand-angle de
80° au niveau de l'écran on a une dalle
ips lcd de 5,99 de diagonale fait un
écran de la marque lg résolution fhd
plus 2160 par 1080 pixels 403 pixels par
pouce bon il fait franchement la sphère
il est assez lumineux en termes de
performance c'est un choc c'est un
médiathèque c'est un ailier au p 23 qui
annonçaient jusqu'à 2.5 gigahertz il
assis giga de ram 64 go de stockage que
vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 128 go avec
une carte micro sd alors très clairement
c'est pas du tout un smartphone
extrêmement puissants relais sur un soc
milieu de gamme
néanmoins pour faire ce que vous avez à
faire là dessus ça ira très bien quand
on est les applications les smartphones
ça va assez vite en plus et une
optimisation logiciels à l'intérieur
pour venir et le libérer de la mémoire
bon c'est plutôt pas mal ça fonctionne
assez bien j'ai fait un petit est sûr en
tout ou on a le score de 91 1928 c'est
pas énorme je vous le dis on est sur un
soc milieu de gamme
ça fait suffisamment la faire pour ce
qu'on lui demande mais là où ça devient
hyper intéressant si au niveau de
l'autonomie avec une batterie de 10000
80 millions père heures c'est juste un
monstre d'autonomie un monstre de
batterie
l'idée d'un smartphone comme ça c'est
lorsque vous partez pendant plusieurs
jours dans des conditions extrêmes de
toujours pouvoir compter sur lui
pouvoir joindre quelqu'un soit en
fonctions talkie walkie soit carrément
en fonction smart phones puisqu'on
pourra utiliser en tout cas le plus
simplement possible l'autonomie est
vraiment là alors une fois de plus ça va
dépendre des usa ça dépend de ce que
vous allez faire ça dépend si vous êtes
vraiment très très loin que lui va
vraiment être obligé de tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps cherché du
réseau parce qu'ils galèrent live à
consommer davantage mais qu'une batterie
de plus de 10 millions terreur vraiment
j'ai pas réussi à les mettre à genoux et
il va vraiment bien c'est pour ça que
vous avez de la recharge rapide c'est
l'accueil de charge 3 24 volts pour
pouvoir avancer parce que si vous le
faites sans recharge rapide ça va m
vachement de temps et vous pouvez le
faire avec une recharge directement en
l'induction par contre ce moment là
prenez votre mal en patience parce
qu'elle lui falloir quand même quelques
heures pour se recharger à 100%
vous avez à l'arrière ici un capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour venir le
déverrouiller ça fait là faire ça
déverrouille assez rapidement c'est pas
le plus rapide que je connaisse
mais vraiment poser votre doigt dessus
ça marche ça réagit vous tournez sur un
android 8.1 oreo il ya une surcouche qui
est très très très légère vous avez
quelques outils en plus vous avez aussi
de quoi mesurer lors que vous allez
marcher ça c'est cool ou calculer votre
nombre de passes assez franchement bien
pour l'extérieur et vous avez plein de
petits outils hyper cool vous avez votre
boussole vous avez un outil qui permet
de mesurer
le volume sonore dans la pièce là on est
à 80 décibels parce que je gueule c'est
beaucoup plus doux fin ça c'est
intéressant et notamment lorsque vous
travaillez sur un lieu qui est vraiment
bruyant ça vous permet de le mesurer et
de voir à quel moment il faut commencer
à partir en courant ça c'est aussi cool
vous avez un outil qui vous permet de
mesurer si votre tableau que vous allez
poser son droit ou pas si vous pouviez
chose à niveau ou pas voyez mon bureau
n'est pas droit vous avez plein de
petits outils qui sont assez
intéressants pour voir si vous êtes bien
positionnés aux cendres vous avez cet
outil là moi qui me rappelle l'école
voilà on peut mesurer des degrés ça
c'est aussi cool vous avez votre plomb
pour être sûr pareil que vous êtes bien
droit enfin voyez il ya plein de change
assez sympa pour me refaire les niveaux
pour poser des tableaux pour poser des
choses à l'écart des choses droite il ya
vraiment tous les outils que vous voulez
donc ça c'est vraiment un côté un peu
plus professionnel
c'est vrai que c'est quand même assez
bien pensé vous êtes aussi partie vous
êtes alors c'est la partie système là
qui vous dit l'utilisation de votre
mémoire before si giga
j'ai deux autres enquêtes giga
d'utiliser je peux le gérer directement
de là je peux le nettoyer je peux gérer
aussi mon autonomie voire un petit peu
où j'en suis au niveau de la batterie
peuvent aussi un mode supérieur saving
up pour vraiment utiliser le moins de
batterie possible par contre forcément
l'écran la luminosité il va diminuer bon
voilà c'est vraiment si vous êtes
bloqués vous pouvez aller là dessus en
tout cas voilà il ya plein de petites
applications qui sont assez sympa mais
surtout la plus intéressante pour moi là
dessus c'est l'option talkie walkie
m mais pour l'utiliser il faut installer
l'antenne
je trouve ça plutôt cool la fonction
talkie walkie maintenant point un peu
négatif pas vraiment négatif mais en
tout cas est limitatif s'est porté en
faux talkie walkie il faut avoir un
talkie walkie en face pour avoir le même
smartphone en face moi en tout cas c'est
strictement pas le cas je n'ai pas
talkie walkie je n'ai pas de deuxième
s80 donc peut pas communiquer mais par
contre c'est assez intéressant parce que
vous avez pas mal de possibilités vous
appuyer là vous mettez à part les
rodgeur rodgeur rodgeur seul point ci
dessous ça cool sinon vous êtes appuyé
la voyez ça marche
vous pouvez venir choisir et si vos
différentes chanel vos différents canaux
sur lesquels vous allez pouvoir
communiquer vous pouvez l'utiliser pour
la communication entre deux personnes
mais en communications group fatou qui
est assez intéressant ça marche pas mal
vous avez des canaux analogiques
vous avez des canaux digitaux et lorsque
vous partez à l'aventuré que vous voulez
un smartphone qui vous permettent de
communiquer comme ça directement en
talkie walkie
là où le réseau ne passe pas sans ça
peut être aussi une bonne solution est
un bon outil aussi bien pour les
professionnels que pour ceux qui partent
à l'aventuré donc ça c'est un point
plutôt positif
ces prêts ont passé une journée à
barouder vous avez envie de vous poser
de réels et du multimédia vous pouvez le
faire sur son écran de 5,99 pousse ça
fonctionne ça va pas trop mal et ce qui
est cool c'est claudio est hyper hyper
performant vous avez beaucoup de sens
alors c'est très médium l'audio est
vraiment là pour venir vous sauver la
vie
lorsque vous allez avoir besoin de
puissance à l'extérieur vous avez 6 de
haut parleurs qui sont franchement
franchement puissance et très médium sa
gueule mais ça marche mais surtout ce
qui fait l'adn de ce produit c'est que
c'est un produit qui est résistant au
froid qui résistant à l'eau je vous dis
de -30 degrés à plus 60 degrés si vous
allez au pôle nord vous aurez patronne
alors peut-être qu'à partir de -40 moins
50 degrés il va commencer un petit
peuvent faire la tronche mais ça devrait
franchement le faire il est certifié ip
68 il est certifié ip 69 cas il est
certifié mil std 810g alors je vais pas
vous détailler les certifications notre
grave parce qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre et retenir c'est que ce
smartphone qui est vraiment fait pour
aller en extérieur qui ne va pas
craindre l'eau la poussière le froid le
chaud qui est robuste qui peut tomber
qui peut prendre des shoots et qui s'en
relèvera toujours
alors bon l'idée c'est pas de le
détruire et le sud sous un caillou mais
en tout cas c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est résistant et c'est vraiment tout
l'adn de ce smartphone
côté photo vidéo c'est pas là où il sera
le meilleur ça me permettra de faire
quelques clichés quelques souvenirs sur
un peu de photos un peu de vidéo
bon c'est pas complètement enfin
franchement c'est pas ou fissiles salut
ça va vous pouvez prendre des photos en
hdr votre beauté mode enfant mode mark
daumail vidéo pour escaliers les cuirs
colle on pouvait filmer en full hd en
1080p vous avez un rendu qui est quand
même pas trop trop malin en termes de
détails lorsque vous regardez comme ça
bon le ce que je pourrais lui reprocher
c'est qu'ils passent stabilisation
optique
parce que forcément ça bouge un peu tout
de suite c'est flou a pas trop trop trop
en demander non plus bon la couleur est
assez bien respecté la couleur de
l'image la caméra de celle ci par contre
c'est pas terrible le traitement de
l'image reste malgré tout très pâle et
dès qu'on arrête tout de suite en
conditions de faible luminosité
très très très imprécis il a tout de
suite beaucoup de mal c'est pas du tout
un smartphone qui est fait pour ça il
est fait pour faire des photos en plein
jour avec la caméra arrière
l'eau reste sinon bon voilà c'est assez
moyen mais de notre côté c'est parce
qu'on va rechercher avec ce smartphone
ce qu'on va rechercher le smartphone
c'est de la solidité et de la robustesse
c'est un smartphone qui va pas craindre
les conditions extrêmes qui fasse
quelques photos à 6 moyenne c'est pas
très grave qu' il soit pas excellent
dans le multimédia c'est pas très grave
ce qui compte vraiment je la fixe où tu
es bien cerner un gain étanche c'est
qu'ils ne craignent absolument pas l'eau
on va se mettre un petit chronomètre est
normalement comme il ya une
certification un et bien il doit pouvoir
résister sans aucun problème ah je vais
faire déborder ça là normalement ça doit
quand même plutôt bien se passer pendant
une demi heure
il ya plus de place pour mettre le claf
on arrive à la fin là ça fait plus de
trente minutes qui dit 37 minutes on va
le sortir et puis on va espérer qu'ils
sont encore vivants mais là mon petit
haut elle donne pause l'écran marche
super bien j'ai l'impression qu'ils
aient un peu moins de volume sonore doit
y avoir de la flotte de danse autant que
ça sachez que ça parte
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai reçu sa décrue de jim leng
demande en mariage
ccc semble pas une bague pour se marier
bizarre et au final non c'est un pis
pour le cinquième anniversaire de la
marque de jeans merci dodji je le remets
dans son écrin de lumière de vix alors
comment je le trouve son équilibre
précaire
comment je trouve au final ce s80 de
djing il est massif
il est énorme il est l'eau ça on va pas
se le cacher d'un autre côté il est
résistant il craint pas les chocs
il craint pas le froid il craint pas le
show il fait talkie walkie
il ya plein d'outils pour venir
travailler pour mesurer l'inclinaison
vous fabriquez une cabane dans un arbre
où vous soyez en train de poser une
planche celle ci n'est pas très droite
voyez je ne l'avais pas fait je suis
très mouvant bricolage pour les
personnes qui vont faire de l'outdoor
pour les professionnels à l'extérieur
c'est un smartphone qui peut être
vraiment très intéressant en plus son
prix il est pas trop mal placé il est à
399 euros bien vu 99 centimes si vous
intéresse je vous aime bien le lien en
bas dans la description pouvait
l'acheter pour moi que ça soit reconnue
chinois pouvaient commander chez
cdiscount directement en france si vous
cherchez vraiment ce typologie de
produits
il fonctionne il ya plutôt bien dites
moi vous maintenant est-ce que des
produits dédiés à l'outdoor peuvent vous
intéresser on vend par les agents les
nôtres a testé j'ai eu les fon vraiment
4x je crois à tester j'ai le croco j'ai
une grosse cole le trekkeur x4 qu'on va
stresser
c'est dur à dire tous ces airs fut le
cros colette rex 4 qu'on va tester d'ici
quelques jours à new york
j'ai pas mal d'autres smartphones comme
ça hein pas testé en outdoor donc ça est
assez intéressant aussi de voir un peu
comparé dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez et puis surtout je vous invite à
consulter ma playlist on parle de tous
les smartphones comme ça vous pouvez
vous faire un avis sur l'ensemble des
produits du marché
voilà d'ici là je vous embrasse soyez
sages et prenez soin de vous ciao